in a lot of multicellular species heart
is one of the most vital organs that
they have including as human right but
this particular species I'm going to
talk about today doesn't have a heart
and this species is called as a
jellyfish that's right they don't have a
heart but they do in fact have a
circulatory system which is more like a
network of channels that circulate fluid
throughout its entire body the fluid
circulation in their bodies is powered
by the rhythmic contraction of their
muscles which helps to circulate the
fluid and distribute oxygen and other
substances throughout its body but did
you know jellyfish is not the only
example nematodes and sea animals also
do not have a heart if you know of any
other multicellular species that do not
have a heart please comment down below
and share it with us and subscribe to
our Channel